>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Kate Julian: Hello and welcome!
My name is Kate Julian
and I'm the deputy editor
of the Sunday Outlook section
of the Washington Post.
The post is very proud
to be a charter sponsor
of this festival again this year.
Before I move onto my remarks
I want to remind all of you
that the pavilions presentations
are being filmed for the Library
of Congress' website
and for their archives.
Please be mindful of this as
you enjoy the presentation.
In addition, please do not sit on
the camera risers that are located
in the back of the pavilion.
Thank you.
It's my great pleasure
to be here today
to introduce Newbery medal award
winning author Rebecca Stead.
[ applause ]
>> Kate Julian: Rebecca has been
writing since she was a child,
but until relatively recently she
worked as a lawyer, not as a writer.
She did some writing on this side
but it was always writing for adults
until as she puts it
the universe intervened.
One of her sons when he was 3
or 4 accidentally pulled her
laptop off the dining room table
with it went all the very
serious grown up stories
that she had been working on.
Rebecca said this about
what came next,
it was time to write something new,
something joyful to cheer me up,
I was pretty grouchy
about the loss of stories.
I went to a bookstore, bought an arm
load of books that I remember loving
as a kid, I read them, I went back
to the store and bought more books.
I read them and then
I began to write.
We are so lucky that she did.
Rebecca's first novel, First Light,
tells the story of a boy named Peter
who joins his parents on
an expedition to Greenland
where they are studying
global warming.
While on the ice cap he encounters
a 14 year old girl named Thea
who has never seen
the sun because she
and her people long ago retreated
to a secret world beneath the ice.
First Light was greeted by
reviewers as an exciting, engaging,
mix of science fiction, mystery and
adventure and as an intriguing look
at how global warming is
affecting the Arctic regions,
deftly woven into a
coming of age story.
Her second novel When You Reach Me,
the recipient of this year's Newbery
medal is that much closer to home,
on the upper west side of
Manhattan during the 1970s.
This is the neighborhood
in which Stead grew up
and it is the same
neighborhood in which she
and her children live today.
When You Reach Me revolves
around Miranda,
a 6th grader whose
world starts to unravel
when her best friend
Sal is punched by a kid
on the street for no obvious reason.
Then starts to shut
Miranda out of his life.
Meanwhile the apartment she shares
with her mother is broken into
and she starts receiving
a mysterious series
of anonymous notes, which
correctly predict the future.
When You Reach Me has already
attracted a very devoted following
of readers for hailing
it as a future classic,
one in the tradition of, tradition
of Madeline L'Engle's,
A Wrinkle in Time.
Please join me in welcoming
Rebecca Stead.
[ applause ]
>> Rebecca Stead: Hi!
Wow! It is a great, great
pleasure to be here.
In the past few months you know I've
gotten invited to some bigger things
and this is no doubt
the biggest so far.
So I'm going to begin if you
can't hear me, can you please wave
and I'll try to project
a little bit better
because I really think
it's frustrating
to sit and just hear muffle.
So please do wave at me if
you can't understand me.
I'm going to start by reading you
an excerpt of the instructions
to the authors appearing at
the National Book Festival.
Presentation guidelines: We
ask for personal thoughts.
These are excerpts,
so I'm skipping words.
Not traditional readings.
Another way of looking at it,
we want to feature the
author's personal perspective
and personality.
Some authors spend part of their
presentation talking about how
and why they became a writer.
Poets may read complete poems, but
should not read very long poems.
Okay, I'm not going to read
you a very long poem and I,
I was trying to think you know
how I could tell you a little bit
about my personality.
It's not that easy, but you
know I think a pretty good way
to start might be telling you
about a dream I have last night.
So last night there was this swank
author's party and it was fabulous
and there were really good cup
cakes and it was you know one
of the fancier things I've
been invited to and I went back
to my hotel room early so I would be
rested for today and fresh for you
and I had you know
demented stress dreams.
So here's the dream
I had last night.
I dreamed that I was going to be
filming a short scene in a movie
and so the next day I was going
to have to get up and say some,
I had some lines I had memorized,
so I, I, I got to the filming spot
and I, I had my lines perfectly
memorized, I like to be in control,
and they said okay great,
so we'll take care of that
and then we're going to
do the second scene and I,
I had no idea what
the second scene was.
So I said what, what, what's
the second, what's the story
in the second scene, so
the second scene turned
out to be a long wordless story
about a dog who falls in love
with another dog and I was to
play the dog who falls in love
and I was going to, you know be
expected to go around on all fours
and you know fall in love as a dog.
And you know I think these dreams
are helpful to us as people
because we wake up and instead
of thinking oh boy I have to get
up in front of a lot of
people today, you get up
and you think thank god I don't have
to do what my sick brain
was just coming up with.
So I do want to tell you a little
bit about how I became a writer
and I want to save at least
half of our time for questions
because you know what's really
special about me here is
that this is an, a blog you know
it's not twitter, it's not facebook
where you know and I love those
things, I, I like feeling sometimes.
I like being in touch with
the people that, that way
but this is something special, I
mean we're all here in this time
in place together, we're looking
at each other face to face and I,
I would love to answer
questions, that's,
that feels like a conversation
and it feels natural
and it is what I like best.
So okay here is my brief
story about becoming a writer.
I am born not too long after
that my parents split up,
so I grew up in New York City
as an only child of divorce
and I have really terrific
truly wonderful parents
and I had a very happy childhood,
which included a lot of time alone.
And I spent a lot of time
reading, and when I finally hit
that sweet spot where
books could take me places,
where I wasn't working to read,
but I was just sort
of writing the story.
I, I, I became really
emotionally entangled with books.
I, I felt incredibly strongly
about them to the point
where I didn't even
really liked talking about,
about books with people because
those felt like my, my places
and they were personal to me and
if you have been there that's great
for you, but I don't really want
to think about it because they felt
like private special worlds.
And Solbelo, who for some
young people here is a writer,
said that a writer is a reader who
is moved to emulation and I think
for many, many people
at least that is true
and it is absolutely true of me.
The only thing is there is a lot
of fear mixed in with my desire
to write and you know I don't
even know if it's a bad thing,
but that fear stopped from
trying to write for a long time.
I started writing in my head, but
I wouldn't put things down on paper
and I think the reason was that I
was afraid of being disappointed.
I was afraid that what was
on the paper wouldn't live
up to my own fantasy really
of what my book would be
and you know I've talked to a
lot of people who seem to feel
that this is really a major obstacle
to, to writing, a lot of people walk
around wanting to write and I
have a theory that you know every,
every kid knows ten people or couple
of people who write all the time
and who have big stacks of
stories and I think for every kid
who is compelled to write and who
has stacks of, of you know stuff
to show for it, there's a kid who
has a, a, like a burning desire
to write, but who isn't putting
down any words at all and I think
that both of those kids
can become writers.
It's probably going to take
the second one a lot longer
than it's going to take the first
one, but they can both get there
and I was that kid who was
writing in my head but I never,
I didn't get many things down
unless I was specifically assigned
to do so.
Okay, so I, I think I can
really describe my childhood
as stepping toward writing
and then away from it.
So in high school I worked in the
program office of my high school
so that specifically so
that I could get myself
into a creative writing
class which was taught
by a great writer named
Frank McCourt
and everybody wanted yes he's,
was wonderful and everybody wanted
to get into this class and you
know your chances just weren't
that great, there were a lot of
people in my high school class
and you really couldn't
take it till you're a senior
and then even then your
chances were pretty slim.
And so I decided that I would
work in the program office
because this was back in the
day where someone just wrote
down your program on your card
and I figured that I could just
if I didn't get it I would just
change it, which I actually didn't
so I spent you know my lunch period
for about three months working
in this office filing so that
I would have the opportunity
to do that.
But then with all of that passion
and, and need to be in this class,
the way he taught was to encourage
us to write and then to have a stand
up and share and read and
that was how it worked
and I could never stand up, I
mean the entire class went by
and I could never get up on my feet.
And you know that was
a lost opportunity
because that's how the class worked.
After college okay there is that,
this big moment college I skipped
because I, I mostly
studies psychology,
I did take a college write, I did
take a creative writing class,
but again I dropped it, it's
that stepping away you know
which I think was about fear.
So after college there's that big
moment you know you're deciding,
everyone's asking you what
you're going to do with your life
and I decided that I would go to
law school which is what I did
and the reason I went
to law school was
because I had taken a practice LSAT
test and done pretty well on it
and I thought oh well
here is something I'm,
I'm good at so that's
what I should do.
And instead of sort of facing the
unknown and some you know writing
which is what I think
was the closest subject
to my heart I thought you know
what it, it would be easier
to do something that I know
I'm going to be pretty good at
and so there are these
you know years and years
of tiny steps forward and back and
it was during my years as a lawyer
that I finally started moving
toward writing in a more serious way
and I think it must have been
because I finally got old enough
to see that I really was at the
point where I was going to have
to start you know working
harder toward my dream.
And you know I have one other, I'm
at my point where I really want
to take questions but I want to say
one other thing, which is that even
after I decided I'm going to write
this is what I'm going to do,
this is what I care about most.
I, I wouldn't, I didn't tell
people and again it was that desire
to protect myself from
disappointment I think
and then I got an encouraging
letter from my editor Wendy Lamb
after I sent her a manuscript
from my first novel First Light
and her letter basically said
there's something here but it needs
to be honed, it needs to
be stronger and tighter
and she helped me create a writing
community which is something
that is essential I
think to every writer.
We really need each other
even though we work alone
and she helped me create a
community of writers and even
when I was working with
these writers on this book
which I then actually had
hopes of getting published,
at this point I was forced to
admit to a few you know friends
that I was trying to write
and you know I constantly
put down my own work.
I would say I'm working on my
stupid book and you know again I,
I was trying to protect myself
from disappointment by putting
down my work I think before
somebody else could do that for me
and so what I want to tell you
is that doesn't work at all.
It doesn't first of all it doesn't
feel good to call your work stupid
and I'm assuming that I'm talking to
at least a few aspiring writers here
and second it doesn't protect
you from the disappointment
because there is no protecting
yourself when you're doing something
that is meaningful to you.
So there you have my personality
and my path to being a writer
and what I would love to do, I'm
really hoping you have questions
if you want to just say them
from your seat I can repeat them
or there is also two microphones
that anybody can come up to
and ask a question about writing
or New York, life, oh I had it,
I could, oh good someone's
going to a microphone,
it's going to say could read,
but I for actually one thing Frank
McCourt did if nobody would stand
up to read their creative work,
we had this grammar book
called Warrener's I don't know
if it's still around, but if
nobody stood up he would just sit
on his desk in the front of the
room and he would sing Warrener's,
Warrener's, Warrener's,
except he sang
in this wonderful Irish [inaudible]
so it was great and that was
like the threat you know,
either get up and start talking
about your fiction or
we're going to do grammar.
So I don't want to
resort to that, yes.
>> Okay, in your book When You Reach
Me why didn't you start each chapter
with things that [inaudible].
>> Rebecca Stead: Okay, so in
When You Reach Me one thing I want
to say is let's avoid spoilers
because When You Reach Me
has a big surprise at the end
and if you could form your
question and that this,
this is not a spoiler,
it's a great question,
but if everyone could form questions
that don't reveal the ending
of the book that will be terrific.
So in When You Reach Me, Miranda,
the main character a 12-year-old
New Yorker living in the 1970s
with her single mom and
her mom has just gotten
on to the $20,000 pyramid right
and she's going to compete
and they're finally going to have
it made because money is a struggle
and Miranda helps prepare her
mom for the game and a lot
of what the game is, is
guessing categories and so
as Miranda is trying to
untangle a very complex,
weird story in her mind,
right, which is sort of a lot
of what the book is, she
is stinking in categories
because at the same time she's
trying to untangle this mystery
of these anonymous
notes she's receiving
and various other mysteries
in her life.
She's helping her mom
practice and the big money
around in the $20,000 pyramid
involves seeing a list of things
and then understanding
what unites them,
what is the common denominator.
So she is framing her
own story in categories.
Yes?
>> When You Reach Me was little more
dark and serious than First Light,
you know I was wondering the
next book you're going to write,
if you're going to write
another one will be more
like When You Reach
Me or First Light?
>> Rebecca Stead: That's
an interesting question,
will the next book be more like
When You Reach Me or First Light.
The main characters at this
point in my next book is a boy
and First Light is told partly
from the point of view of a boy,
there's two characters, one the
boy, one the girl and I have
to say it's going to be
more like When You Reach Me,
not in terms of the plot but
in term, but in its attempt
to acknowledge some of the
harder, darker sides of childhood.
Yes.
>> I have a question about Frank,
your class with Frank McCourt.
Didn't he make you stand
up and read at some point?
I think you said you never did.
>> Rebecca Stead: No.
He never made us stand up, he
didn't force you to stand up.
Frank McCourt did not force you
stand up, he didn't call on you
and you know may be he
should have, I don't know,
I might have just collapsed
on the spot.
Yes.
>> What inspired you to
write When You Reach Me?
>> Rebecca Stead: Ah,
the plot was inspired
by a newspaper article I read
about a man with amnesia.
It was a story in the
times about a guy
in North West part of the country.
He was walking around and he
realized he had no idea who he was
or where he's from and he
started going up to people
on the street and asking for help.
He eventually, they all
ran away from him of course
and he eventually found a
police officer who brought him
to a hospital and under hypnosis
he remembered things that,
he remembered a terrible accident
and when, when they finally figured
out who this guy was, this
accident had not yet happened.
So it, this whole story just gave
me the idea about people walking
around with memories of their
futures and that was the inspiration
for the plot and then a lot
of the story was inspired
by my own childhood in New
York City, it's set in the time
and the place of my growing up
and one the main characters,
the laughing man is someone who, who
we called the laughing man who stood
on my corner pretty much all
the time and I was afraid of him
and I would run by him, you know
at a full sprint everyday on my way
to school and that character became
woven into the story and along
with a lot of other
memories of childhood.
Yes.
>> What book do you think
you enjoyed more and why?
>> Rebecca Stead: Enjoy writing.
>> No, what, yeah writing.
>> Rebecca Stead: You know I
actually think that my first novel,
First Light, was an attempt
to create the kind of story
that I loved reading as a kid.
I was a big fantasy and science
fiction fan and I loved secrets
and mysteries and secret
worlds and I think that a,
I drew a lot of inspiration from my
own love of reading and so it kind
of led me toward the kinds of
books I loved reading as a kid.
The second book is much, a much
more of a delving into the kind
of person I was as a kid and
the kind of weird thoughts I had
as a kid and it is a little darker
in a way and, and truer probably
to who I am and who I
was you know at 11, 12,
13 and they're completely different
types of pleasure you know.
I loved writing both of them.
I think the second one was
probably a little bit more organic
because I was just pulling stuff
out of my brain and,
and out of my memory.
So I, I guess I'm avoiding
your question.
I'm sorry, it's so hard to say, but
I, I think if I had to lean one way
or the other I would say
When You Reach Me had some,
some moments of intense
like pleasure,
like I'm finally expressing
what I feel about somethings
and what I think about childhood
and that was pretty wonderful.
Yes.
>> I'm a children's librarian and
read in the school library journal
that the reason you said the story
in the 60s was having
you contemporary was
because in the story as a
[inaudible] devices helpful
for Miranda to have
more freedom and I know
if my own child we were much
less supervised at that time,
which do you think is better
for children developmentally
to be given the freedom or freedom
or having your more supervision now.
>> Rebecca Stead: Wow!
I'm not an expert.
I do think that kids at age 11 and
12 really benefit from the knowledge
that we see them as capable people
and we don't think that they need
to be completely protected.
I mean I like every parent think
it's important to protect children
and like every person
parent or non-parent,
but at the same time I think it's
important for the kids to see
that we trust them and that we
know that they're self-possessed
and that they possess judgment
and even if they make mistakes,
you know life goes on and you
know if I, I would feel terrible
if you know my 12-year-old got into
it on the street with somebody,
he would be really, really upset
and he got something
taken away from him.
He would be upset by it, but
life would, life goes on,
I mean he would also get past it
and he would be okay and so I,
I do think it's important to get
kids a measure of independence
as long as you know it's
ultimately basically safe.
Yes.
>> In your book it
talks about landing
in the Broccoli patch
and seeing yourself.
I actually didn't notice that,
the first time I read it,
but after I read your
book I noticed that line.
Did that in some way inspire
you to write the book?
>> Rebecca Stead: That
part of A Wrinkle in Time.
You know actually no,
I had, Miranda was,
Miranda loves the book A Wrinkle
in Time and she's carrying it
around through the
book and I wasn't sure
that the book was going
to stay in my book.
I thought you know this is
sort of a prop to remind me
of the kind of kid Miranda is.
But A Wrinkle in Time you
can't just throw it in there,
I mean people have a lot of
strong feelings about this book
and it's an important book
in a lot of ways to many,
many people of different generations
and I decided to re-read the book
as one of the characters in my book.
Now this is getting
very you know meta...
I decided you know what since a lot
of Miranda came from my own memory,
I'm going to try to read A Wrinkle
in Time from the point of view
of Marcus, who's a character
who's very unlike Miranda,
right in When You Reach
Me and that was
when I saw it for the first time.
When I sort of tried to channel
this character or Marcus who's
like a very scientific thinker and
that was one when I first noticed it
and then thought ooh this is
great, you know this gives me a way
to really start opening up
questions about time and reality
and what could happen and so that
is when I had the idea to use it.
I mean it was not early at all in
the process of writing the book,
it was like a little gift.
Yes?
>> So, in when You Reach Me
there's sort of a circular plot
and every detail comes
together in the end.
>> Rebecca Stead: Thank you.
>> Did it just come together
that way or did you [inaudible].
>> Rebecca Stead: Ah, did the
plot just come together that way,
you know yes and no,
I sometimes think
that writing a book is a little
bit like one summer in camp,
I built this wooden box and it,
it was sort of loosely assembled
it first and then I had to kind
of tighten everything at once so
that it would all come out straight
and it's that's kind of like good
analogy for, for finishing a book
like this because there're all
these rough eng, edges and things
that are slightly unbalanced or
off and you, you know I did want it
to be completely straight
and I wanted it
to make sense and to really satisfy.
You know that was always my
question, does it satisfy
and so what we did was we
had fresh readers, my editor
and I asked people who had
never read the book before
to read it every time I had a
new draft and there were a number
of drafts and we asked them
where did you get snagged,
where did you get confused,
where do this become predictable,
where and you know because the
book requires a certain amount
of tolerance of confusion.
You'll have to be willing
to be confused for a while
and you know I don't underestimate
the people who are reading my book
and I ask a fair amount of you
know a fair amount from the.
I expect them to be working a little
when they're reading and so it was
like a long process of refinement.
It, it was not just sort of
organic way that came out that way.
I sort of, I had the basic idea, but
it needed a lot of little things.
>> Thank you.
>> Rebecca Stead: Thanks.
>> Did you watch the $20,000
pyramid yourself in the 70s.
>> Rebecca Stead: I did watch
the $20,000 pyramid in 70s
and actually my mom was a
contestant on the $20,000 pyramid.
But she actually a surprising
number of people it turns
out have been contestants
on that show.
A lot of people have come to
me and said my sister was on it
or I was on it, my dad was on it.
My mom didn't win, so this was
like you know important
for me to revisit.
We did win consolation
prizes including like a crate
of dentine gums that we
dutifully chewed for months.
Yes.
>> How did you react when you got
the award for When You Reach Me?
>> Rebecca Stead: Ah,
how did I react?
I was stunned and joyful.
Yes.
>> Okay, I have two things,
one my mom was on Jeopardy,
she didn't win either but and...
>> Rebecca Stead: We should talk.
>> Yes and my question, my question
is if you could write the book
from either point of view of Sal
or Marcus , who would you do?
>> Rebecca Stead: Sal or Marcus.
That would be interesting.
I don't know.
May be Sal.
Which would you most want to read?
>> Probably Marcus.
>> Rebecca Stead: Oh, Marcus then.
Yes. Ah, oh, okay,
we're in overtime.
So one more, okay sorry guys.
Oh, I before we're done, done, I
just want to say that I'm going
to I, I ran out of time at the
reading, I mean at the signing,
and some people who I wanted
to meet I didn't get to meet
and I'm really sorry for that
because it was a hot long line.
So I, we, we try, we, we
added a short second signing,
so and I have instructions, it's
going to start at if you want
to come and then 1:30, I
going to try to sign for 20
or even 25 minutes, may be
and then I'm going to sprint
to somewhere else and it's
line 14, so line 14 at 1:30,
I'm going to do a little
bit more signing.
Yes.
>> When You Reach Me
got the Newbery,
so did you read the second
place winner, the Newbery honor.
>> Rebecca Stead: Wow.
Ah, there were a bunch
of second place.
Well I don't want to you know,
they're not second place,
I guess that you're,
they're honors, right.
I have not read the honor books.
Yeah you know what I have to say
that for a while now
I've been reading a,
a lot of what you would
call adult books and I find
that when I'm trying to write a
new book which I have been trying
to do very much for
the last nine months
since before the Newbery
was announced.
I've been fiddling with different
kinds of gas really you know
like other people's books are kind
of like gas in the tank for me
and so, sometimes it's
actually more productive for me
to read adult books than it is
for me to read children's books
and may be it's because it's so
different from what I'm creating.
But so I have been mostly
focusing on those, so I have a pile
of books next to my bed which is
like up to here, which I'm going
to get to as soon as
finish this darn book
that I'm writing right now.
Okay, thank you.
It was a tremendous
pleasure to be here.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us as loc.gov.